so I got this guy's number the other
night and I don't know if I should wait
for him to call me or she call him this
is totally pretty basic stuff there's a
scientific formula for this max there's
no science of this sort of thing you
just have to feel it definitely not now
but soon don't wait too long no no dude
just like it's at yourself the universe
will give me a sign oh we see that now
do what right there right outside our
window look I'm crazy looking good okay
so if the guy is G and time is X then
you just divide the number of hours and
series I need to take into consideration
we both have each other's numbers and
then we met on a Sunday which is the
start awful workweek
wait oh it's my phone that's my phone
doing out here oh who are you you're my
spirit guide aren't you hmm
how do I know when to call her oh I've
got her number right here where'd he go
for the past five weeks fit obituary in
the LA Times 2015 has started with the
fifth letter in the alphabet e this
crossword puzzle replace five down five
across with all is hold on this is
getting out of hand how many fingers on
your hand
where are you Oh Oh God how do you keep
doing that
are you saying that bananas bruise
quickly that I should call all the time
he's right Oh Oh what where do you go
same white van it's driven past three
times now they're on to a swift turn
front off when you turn over front side
then how will you know if he's calling
you right you're right it's not just an
equation for when to call it's connected
to everything is bad how about I need to
call someone for you I legitimately
think that you might be losing your mind
ah what does it mean why is it a banana
why did I follow you here when do I call
wait I'll just call him yeah it's 2015
call him what oh I'll just call her yeah
I'll just come with it oh she's calling
me what hello hey hey I was literally
just about to call you
I know I would like to I would like to
go to dinner with you yeah yeah what
time is good for you
whatever five okay yeah that seems a
little early bit yeah no that's fine
yeah that's great
awesome we're cool
banana